[Music]
nicholas is with us in kansas city hi
nicholas how are you
hey miss ramsay i'm good how are you
doing better than we deserve what's up
i actually was calling in i was just
hoping to get some advice on uh maybe a
potential job switch um
and so
right now i'm i'm in the mortgage
business and it's a little hard um
and i think this last year my my eyes
were a little bigger than my stomach so
i ended up i bought a car and a house
um but other than that that's the only
debt i have
um i have
you know the ira set up 401k i got some
investments going on
but i feel like
i'm kind of getting in over my head if i
have no because i'm commissioned fully
i have no uh
i don't really have many deals coming in
right now because it's
it's just uh
you know the rates are super high it's
hard to get
some of these locked in so i have a
salary
job or potentially a salary job set up
i'm just wondering if i should be
looking to sticking it out here or
if i should uh think about maybe
switching into something that's more
stable
what's the salary job pay and what is it
uh so it's an asset-based lending um and
so the salary would be around 125 to
150.
so like commercial deals
uh yes sir well
yeah um commercial
lending and as far as like uh corporate
loans go
um okay
all right
do you want to do that
uh i mean i so i graduated in 2019 and i
graduated finance and banking degree and
that's how i got into in the mortgages
um but that's what my my dad does so
i've been thinking about getting into
that uh just because you know it would
be
commissioned
eventually but
the the salary seems it just seems more
stable and
uh i don't know i feel like i'm kind of
in over my head right now
with the the mortgage in the car note
and well part of this
part of this is a career question but
part of it is we got to get you out of
debt
and so can you sell the car is it worth
more than you paid for it still
um i think it's about right around the
same
yeah
uh sorry around 18 000 okay and the the
payment's right around 400.
yeah i mean you can pay this thing off
and keep it but it's not you keep saying
you're in over your head i don't know is
the 400 bucks a month tanking you you
have no margin left at the end of the
month
you're also investing too and so that's
another piece of the puzzle
right so i don't want to pull out
anything from my investments and
obviously uh from like the the ira and
the retirement stuff but um i that the
mortgage is really kind of
okay so hitting me hard yeah so so
basically without refi in the pipeline
the mortgage business is really
struggling
because nobody's refined because
everybody's got a three percent mortgage
they're not gonna refi to a five or a
six
and so uh the only mortgage is coming
through a purchase money mortgage just
meaning people buying houses right now
so the volume that you've got as an
originator is way down so your income is
way down
and that's likely to be that way for a
little while uh that's not going to fix
in the next three months um it's going
to be you know it's going to be a long
hot summer
um so
in your world
so the um
the question though is okay i don't have
much income coming in i really need to
get a job or i can make some money
and then this other thing pops up
so i i think i do agree
that if you want to leave the mortgage
business because you're not making any
money and go make some money and
go get a job make some money i think i
agree with that idea i'm not sure
which job you would take though
i think i want you more excited i don't
i want you to run to something as much
as from something and right now it feels
like in this conversation you're just
running from something
right i think that's kind of my biggest
uh struggles is depending you know
the salary sounds good because that's
coming in each month but then
you know i really want to be doing this
ten years from now and it kind of sounds
like no
right
it sounds like i'm taking this because i
need some money
because i'm not making any right now
well and another
another big thing that i want to kind of
do is i i
while i'm younger i want to be able to
have my money work for me and kind of
grow my my money but if i'm just getting
a paycheck each month and putting it
towards my mortgage and you know my car
i don't really have i
you know i can't contribute well i'll
contribute to the 401k but i can't max
the ira i can't really have you know any
more investments um and those will come
back i understand that but so what what
i'm telling you is quit analyzing your
career
based on one
piece of data as and that one piece of
data is income
it is one of the things you need to look
at
but you also need to look at
what the long term play is
am i going to be doing this 20 years is
there a progression here can i go up can
i can i move up the ladder in this
process can i make more and more and
more or is this i'm taking a dead-end
job because i need a salary shut up
you know don't do that
you there's other options out there
with what i'm doing now there's a
potential to maybe move up and own a
branch but then also the
the asset-based funding that's that's
got potential to then you know get
salary also and then start doing my own
deals to where the commission will then
roll in yeah and that's that's what my
dad does so you know i care what your
dad does oh and i want to know what you
want to do
how old are you nicholas
i'm 25. yeah okay don't take a job
because you're not making any money so
that you can make a salary
take a job that you think is going to be
thrilling
10 years from now 15 years from now and
your income will have gone up
and along the way you solved the salary
issue too
uh uh so
uh they tend to go hand in hand the
thing you're really excited about they
should be great at and tend to get paid
well to do it they should so i think you
ought to look at two or three other
things while you're doing this and see
if if the decision-making paradigm that
you're using brings you back to this
after you've been on this in other words
before you marry this girl go on a date
with some others
and it'll lead you right back to her if
she's your true love
and uh if it if it doesn't then you go
yeah she was just you know
just
no so yeah i'm gonna stretch that
metaphor way too far there but um i'm
gonna leave it alone but the uh um
yeah so so yeah don't
only take a job because of income and
don't only take a job because of
passion and purpose and ignore income
yeah
that's dumb too i'm gonna send you two
books one is from paycheck to purpose
our friend ken coleman's book that's
gonna help you find that thing that you
can do and get paid well to do it and
i'm gonna send you a copy of the total
money makeover so hang on austin will
pick up and i hope that book shows you
that man if we stop investing for a
little while to pay off this debt we're
going to really feel the progress we're
not going to feel like we're beyond our
skis here and part of that like dave
he's saying i want to invest more but i
can't because i don't have the money
because i'm paying a car payment and
that's what debt does it steals from
your future and so i want you to get out
of debt and if that means selling the
car because you're so excited about
investing and you drive a hooptie i'm
okay with that but you got to make a
choice here we can't be going in three
directions and then wonder why we're not
making progress yeah
and you know what he's experiencing
george is the old buffett saying
you know you you can tell who was skinny
dipping when the tide goes out
so all these things he was doing
was okay as long as you're making money
but as soon as the mortgage business
dried up then all of a sudden these
stupid things look pretty stupid you got
exposed yep you got it shows you it
shows you know you're when you're stupid
is stress stress tested it comes out
looking
well stupid i mean that's how that works
and that's happened to me it's happened
to you it's happened to everybody out
there
and so
um you know if you're making really good
money it could cover uh as they say a
multitude of sins a multitude of
stupidity
uh but as soon as your your income dries
up a little bit or tightens up a little
bit all of a sudden you go well that one
too smart well you've told you've told
everyone you've tried to out earn your
stupidity yeah i did i tried it it
didn't work because apparently my income
potential is not as high as my stupid
potential
so um which is infinite i don't know
apparently careful george sorry hey
you're a sharp guy we all know that
careful george we're poking fun at old
dave not new dave
it's different
i'm not sure what to do with that
exactly